k
[Música]
Olhas amigas meus amigos sejam
bem-vindos para mais uma live Boa noite
Carlinha huberg Eliane Estela Mares por
favor vão me dizendo se vocês estão
escutando bem se o áudio tá passando com
qualidade você tá
estourando eu V aguardar a resposta de
vocês hoje tem pouca
pergunta tem sete perguntas se eu não me
engano
eu vou falar sobre umas notícias
interessantes no mundo do
Alzheimer eu tô testando uma automação
nova que pega as notícias do mundo
inteiro eu escolhi o assunto Alzheimer e
também reposição hormonal Isso vai ser
uma das fontes também de Notícias que
nós vamos utilizar aqui no nosso
encontro semanal bem Eu tô aguardando
vocês me responderem se está ok o
microfone
pra gente poder dar continuidade mas até
lá
vamos responder às
dúvidas Deixa eu só localizar o
documento das
dúvidas onde que está o questionário
está aqui
não não é esse
esse
aqui
OK colocar ele junto aqui
pronto vou dividir a tela com vocês
aqui som beleza som está ótimo Ok vamos
continuar então boa noite Eliseu
eu acho que tá fácil para vocês lerem né
primeira pergunta
querido amigo por favor você poderia
fazer um vídeo sobre os probióticos em
especial com a comparação da eficácia de
cada um
deles Desde já agradeço que mandou foi o
Francisco Weber Obrigado pelas palavras
Francisco
é complicado
comparar os vários probióticos naturais
viu mas eu vou tentar ver se a gente
acha ciência a respeito disso que a
questão aí é que não sei se vai ter
tanto estudo por conta de não ser coisas
patenteáveis
né Porque que a gente sabe sobre a veia
fermentada é que ela pode conter
probióticos como lactobacilos e
bifidobacterium a diversidade e a
quantidade de cepas vai variar de acordo
com o método de fermentação dos
microorganismos envolvidos então iso é
um problema porque vamos dizer que eu
ache artigo sobre aveia fermentada mas
como é que eu vou
comparar o que foi achado Nesse artigo
com que tá acontecendo na casa de cada
um de vocês aí que estão fermentando
aveia né que não é exatamente o mesmo
processo de
fermentação o Kefir do leite vai ter
basicamente lactobacilos
acidófilos e bí bactério bid
e vai ter também
leveduras geralmente São 30 ou mais
tipos diferentes de
cepas então Teoricamente o kefi de leite
vai ter mais cepas do que a veia
fermentada mas Teoricamente
né
e não sei se vai dar para fazer esse
vídeo sinceramente
bem em relação comparação dos dois
pessoas com tolerância lactosa é
obviamente que vai ser melhor usar a
veia
fermentada eu vou estudar esse assunto
viu weber para ver se de fato vai ser
interessante fazer esse
vídeo próxima pergunta Dr Alan Dutra
quero que o senhor analise esquecendo o
conteúdo político mais como médico o
professor Olá de Carvalho deixou gravado
escrito em vídeos e diversos textos que
toxoplasmose poderia ser uma das causas
da burrice brasileira uma teoria
interessante eu não conhecia a minha
pergunta é se seria possível boa parte
de uma nação contaminada com essa doença
Possível é mas na verdade a grande
maioria das pessoas vão
estar com o agente no corpo mas não vão
ter desenvolvido a doença clinicamente
significativa ela emburrece a pessoa a
ponto de causar os sintomas que o
professor deixou escrito só um cérebro
sem destruído pela toxoplasmose pode ser
incapaz de perceber de imediato o horror
moral daquilo que o general Mourão disse
do Povo
venezuelano bem eu não sei se tava
levando a sério essa história ele já é
falecido já tem uns 3 4 anos né O olá
cavalho se eu não me
engano mas tem mais um ano que ele é
falecido eu não sei se é dois três ou
quatro eu não sei se tá falando de to m
de uma maneira assim
realmente levando a sério ou ele tava
sendo irônico
né a doença toxoplasmos meso ela vai se
desenvolver em quem tá com sistema
imunológico comprometido ou em bebês que
estão na barriga das
mães que tem o agente
ativo mas existe um pessoal da Medicina
integrativa que acha que a toxoplasmose
realmente é muito mais prevalente como
doença não como simplesmente o agente
que sensibilizou o sistema imune né que
tem muita gente que teve contato mas não
desenvolveu a doença só tem imunidade
então tem muita gente dentro da Medicina
integrativa mais pro lado da quântica
que acredita que a toxoplasmose é um
problema muito sério no
Brasil mas eles usam ferramentas de
medicina quântica para poder chegar a
essa conclusão e não exames
laboratoriais Geralmente os sintomas
neurológicos da encefalite por
toxoplasmose não é bem a redução da
Inteligência
tá
a toxoplasmos no cérebro pode provocar
depressão
ansiedade mas geralmente não redução
Global da inteligência ou problema
julgamento bem eu vou dar uma pesquisada
nesse
assunto mas eu acho complicado viu que
essa frase seja realmente
cientificamente plausível
eu sempre esqueço que a a taquinha é
Maria Helena Por que que você não muda o
nome desse usuário taquinha para Maria
Helena era melhor
né
porque me confunde né
esses nomes aí
substitutos Boa noite D an Paulo
Rodrigues Que honra você estar aqui na
nossa Live muito obrigado viu agora que
eu
percebi mas eu vou dar uma olhada nessa
história da toxoplasmose viu para te
falar Antônio Renato
tem uma pro próximo
aqui D Alan por favor ajude a entender o
meu problema ah pessoal já falei várias
vezes isso pessoal tá mandando exames
para eu analisar como se fosse uma
consulta Eu já falei várias vezes aqui
que não é esse o objetivo do
grupo da comunidade do canal
fechado eu vou ver por cima para não
parecer chato
parecer implicante mas isso aqui não
pode ser uma consulta médica online
tá mas vamos lá vamos tentar ajudar de
alguma
maneira digestão difícil estofamento e
gás
excessivos os achados estômago
hiperplasia foveolar R diato comprom
Lemos você fez exame no comprom Lemos
mas quem é que te pediu esse exame você
tá ao
vivo mas vamos lá Alfa mon tripsina
fecal baixo estamina fecal
alta melatonina fecal baixa elastase
pancreática fecal baixa gordura fecal
baixa ins exócrina do
pâncreas exame de sangue Alfa um anti
tripsina baixa tc de abdômen com
contraste pâncreas Basto e adrenal sem
particularidades mesmo suplementando
qualidade betaína pepsina
fitomelatonina adal não consigo fazer o
pâncreas produzir as enzimas aí pr
suplementação da pancreatina
exógena Foi testar a suação com tripsina
não houve Resultado positivo mas S
negativo como alta da homocisteína eu
não acho que a suplementação que causou
isso não Ferritina subiu parei com
tripsina que a tripsina tenha afetado a
sua mí Será que favorecendo a
colecistocinina ou outra coisa conso
ativação do pâncreas tem tem pode ser
uma disbiose que não tá deixando o teu
pâncreas funcionar aí tem que tratar
disbiose aí eu não vi nada aí que você
tá falando que seja tratamento de
disbiose ou vou ter que experimentar pro
resto da vida provavelmente não mas tem
gente que tem que suplementar pancreatin
No resto da vida sim tá o que eu posso
fazer para melhorar isso marcar consulta
para avaliar
disbiose eu preciso realizar o exame de
fenotipagem Alfa 1 antipina ajuda em
alguma
coisa bem eu nunca pedi esse exame não
sei te dizer se vai ajudar eu já me
virei muito bem sem esse exame né mas
por favor não façam mais esse tipo de
pergunta o rubert tá ruberg né ele tá
Perdoado porque ele é novo aqui no canal
tá ele Talvez não tenha lido
eh as regras que tem lá no canal
desculpa no grupo do WhatsApp então ele
tá
perdoado Porém isso aqui ru eu não posso
analisar exames seus numa Live tá isso
não é consulta médica mas eu te digo o
que eu me parece seu caso é que você tá
com uma disbiose
tem que ser tratada geralmente é tratado
com antibiótico natural e probiótico Ok
essa suplementação aqui com enzima
digestiva mas adal não é o suficiente
ajuda mas não é o suficiente ok Porque
tem que descobrir porque que o seu
pâncreas não tá
produzindo enzima digestória suficiente
que a causa mais comum é disbiose e cibo
Ok a a estamina fecal
alta ela pode ser também uma em
decorrência dessa desse cibo dessa
disbiose quando você corrige a cibo
disbiose a estamina cai
tá espero ter ajudado mas eu não posso
fazer mais do que isso tá não posso
fazer consulta no meio de uma live aqui
hã próxima
pergunta Dr Alan mesmo que uma pessoa
beba quantidade de água de acordo com
seu peso e tamanho caso ela tenha
diabetes ainda assim pode ter
insuficiência renal
bem Eu tô aqui pensando porque eu não
sei se eu entendi essa
pergunta o ponto aqui é que o Diabetes
tem que tá bem
controlado ou revertido aí você vai tá
preservando função
renal tá então independente da
quantidade de água a pessoa pode se
hidratar
bem mas se tiver com açúcar do sangue
descontrolado
ela vai desenvolver uência renal do
mesmo jeito só que vai ser um tipo
diferente de insistência renal enquanto
que a desidratação vai ser uma insuf
renal
pré-renal a insuf renal por falência
renal por causa do diabetes vai ser uma
uência renal renal tá então mesmo que
esteja bem hidratado se a glicose do
sangue ficar muito tempo descontrolado o
Diabetes correndo solto vai ter insua
renal era essa a pergunta que você tava
fazendo você tá ao vivo
voltando à pergunta do Hubert ou
huert ele fez uma pergunta de um exame
específico que
é fenotipagem Alfa 1 antitripsina esse
exame ele é um exame para diagnosticar
deficiências genéticas E no caso do
huger o problema pode ser muito mais
relacionado à cibo disbiose Ok então
esse exame eu acho que não é tão útil
não próxima pergunta a hidratação ideal
pode impedir tanto AVC como
infarto Com certeza hidratação vai ser
muito importante para ajudar a impedir
AVC infar obviamente que isoladamente
não vai ser o
suficiente quando está bem hidratado o
seu corpo vai funcionar de maneira muito
mais adequada porque o seu sangue vai tá
correndo com uma fluidez melhor as
enzimas vão tá funcionando
melhor tudo vai tá funcionando melhor no
organismo então beber água insuficiente
quantidade pode ajudar a manter os vasos
sanguíneos flexíveis e a pressão
arterial estável isso vai reduzir o
risco de doenças ou problemas
cardiovasculares só que é Além disso né
prevenção de a infato vai envolver dieta
adequada antiinflamatória exercício
regular controle do estresse não fumar
eh gerenciamento de doenças de base né
se você tiver hipertensão
arterial diabetes ou des epidemia tudo
isso tem que ser bem cuidado
e os suplementos que vão ajudar bastante
né como natoquinase
picnogenol antioxidantes de modo geral
ômega3 minerais com Magnésio e
potássio
certo se você tiver ao vivo aí Antônio
Renato me diga se
você entendeu se eu respondi a sua
pergunta Ok próxima pergunta é verdade
que o excesso de vinagre de maçã reduz o
potássio e aumenta per da óssea podendo
ocasionar osteopenia
osteoporose nesse quase o que seria
excesso em miligramas nesse
quase bem eu acho que o excesso de
vinagre de maçã pode reduzir o potássio
sim mas o que que seria excesso
né se você ingerir por exemplo uma
colher de sopa de vinagre de maçã por
dia não é excesso o que está
considerando excesso
Eliane bem os efeitos colaterais mais
comuns do consumo excessivo de vinagre
de
maçã então se você consumir em grande
quantidade ele vai potencialmente afetar
o equilíbrio o ácido básico do organismo
isso pode levar a perda de minerais como
você comentou incluindo o cálcio mas
teria que estar ingerindo muito né Eu
acho bem Improvável na no dia a dia na
prática você fazer
isso eu acho difícil uma pessoa ingerir
mais de duas colheres de sopa por dia de
vinagre de maçã né então quando você faz
essa pergunta você tá pensando em
excesso em que sentido Por que que você
tá preocupado com
excesso Você tá tomando muito vinagre de
maçã você tá ouvir você pode me dizer
para eu poder te ajudar de uma outra
forma
bem vamos continuar
aqui antes de continuar vamos ver aqui a
os
comentários geralmente a fermentação
aumenta estamina sim
viu sim é foi isso mesmo que ele quis
associar com certeza
Ana sim a
microangiopatia bom acho que eu respondi
à dúvida
né no caso em
miligramas miligramas de vinagre de
maçã geralmente a gente não mede por
miligrama né por ml né
mililitro É verdade que de maçã só
fermenta se colocar
açúcar não veja bem o vinagre de maçã já
é fermentado
Eliseu fermentação
acética e essa fermentação sempre vai
acontecer em cima de o açúcar no caso o
açúcar aí o
açúcar natural da fruta não precisa
colocar açúcar adicionado tá então toda
a fermentação utiliza açúcar como
substrato seja acética ou alcoólica Tá
mas esse açúcar que você tá se referindo
é o açúcar da fruta né que puseram o
açúcar está União na na maçã
não seria em cápsulas o ingresso de maçã
ser o vinagre de maçã ah Nesse caso tem
que se preocupar menos ainda né é só
seguir a orientação de quem gente
prescreveu e não passar da quantidade
que tá prescrita eu não tô te entendendo
porque você tá tão preocupada com essa
quantidade do vinagre isso na prática
não é relevante
Eliane bem vamos continuar as perguntas
aqui
uma próxima pergunta da Maria
Helena que é a
tamin Ok não sei porque que ela tem esse
nome no no
YouTube qual seria uma dose segura de B3
para adulto na forma hexanicotinato de
inositol B3 no
flush as doses habituais que a gente usa
disso aí é de 500 a 2 g por dia 500 mg a
2000 por dia tá então você pode
considerar essa dose segura de 500 mg a
2000 MG ou 2 g por dia
OK ão simples
assim
ah próxima
pergunta Ué não tem mais pergunta
aqui eu acho que foi a última deixa eu
ver se não você não tá aparecendo aqui é
porque acabou mesmo então deix cutir os
artigos com vocês mas antes tem
perguntas do Eliseu
aqui depois de fazer ozon terapia para
her de disco Qual é o exame que devo
fazer para saber se a disco foi curada
uma ressonância ressonância de coluna
Eliseu Antes de iniciar sessões de
ozonioterapia para de disco se eu quiser
ver no r x a imagem da herne de disco
não é um bom exame para ver isso não é
ressonância são exames de ressonância
tem que comparar a ressonância antes da
ozônio com a ressonância depois do
ozônio r x não é um bom exame para verna
de disco
alguma coisa acrescentar D Ana Paula
pergunta dicas para Natal e Ano
Novo quem já Como é que é você tá
perguntando ou você tá pedindo para
alguém perguntar
dicas pro natal e ano novo tá vou dar
uma aqui não encha a
cara fique bem
hidratado Não coma demais não deixe de
fazer atividade
física
pronto enviou uma pergunta vamos ver se
chegou
aqui chegou chegou a pergunta me dá só
um instante aqui
bem vamos ver a sua
pergunta
ã ele estava levando a sério falou em
vários vídeos Obrigado por você se
comprometer a analisar com mais atenção
Aqui está a frase do Mourão não tem
outra solução enquanto ele tiver apoio
militar
a população contrária a madura está
desarmada e tem que estar porque senão
iríamos para uma guerra civil que seria
horrível para o
continente ele tiver apoio militar você
está falando maduro a população
contrária maduro está desarmada e tem
que estar porque senão iríamos para uma
guerra civil guerra civil lá né Não aqui
né que seria horrível para o continente
essa traz analisada corretamente vinda
de um general e realmente lógica
irracional mas a minha não é não não é
totalmente irracional nem lógica não
agora não entendi o que ele quis dizer
com iríamos iríamos Quem o povo da
Venezuela ou o povo do
Brasil mas a minha pergunta é se o
cérebro destruído não é destruído né o a
toxoplasmos não destrói o cérebro causa
problema de inteligência e se isso seria
possível a nível Nacional eu assisti ele
falando em um vídeo gravado que uma
pessoa do ciclo social dele sugeriu isso
meio
chocado Mas depois foi pensar e chegou à
conclusão que isso poderia ser verdade
devido a tanta
burrice bem essa frase do Mourão não
entendi porque que ela causou
tanto tanta comoção é uma frase meio
esquisita mesmo Mas por que que essa
frase quer dizer que o povo brasileiro
tem toxoplasmose por isso que é
burro tô achando meio estranha essas
correlações
aí mas enfim é um assunto de certa forma
interessante eu vou dar uma olhada nisso
aí tá
pergunta do Eliseu considerando uma
herna de disco lombar não grave quantas
sessões Deon terapia em média são
suficientes para curar ah Eliseu
primeira coisa que eu te digo que não é
assim não viu
ozonoterapia não é que vai curar a herne
de disco não pode até acontecer se for
uma erne disco pequena
né eu não te daria nem essa média alu
porque na na
prática essa cura não é comum
não ao fazer o zio terapia para de disco
no momento que a dor desaparecer
significa que a em de disco foi curada e
que já pode interromper as sessões
não não quer dizer que curou só porque a
dor passou não
Eliseu envi outra porque você não envia
aqui se é ao vivo era você podia enviar
por aqui né mas vamos ver
eh como a pessoa pode saber se tem
toxoplasmose tem que fazer exame
sorológico
Ok tem tratamento tem cura sim tá tem
tratamento e cura
o tratamento de toxoplasmose é feito com
antibióticos ele de certa forma ele é
parecido com o tratamento de tuberculose
é um tratamento longo você tem que fazer
por vários meses
o desafio é que as pessoas geralmente
infectadas não têm
sintomas em muitos casos pode haver
sintomas leves febre dor de cabeça dor
de garganta inchaço dos gânglios isso
vai passar como uma
virose os grupos de risco são mulheres
graves que podem passar pro feto aí pode
ter realmente malformações graves e
pessoas que TM o sistema de defesa o
sistema imune comprometido como aquelas
que estão fazendo
quimioterapia ou que tem HIV
aides né então você faz os exames
sorológicos são exames que
detectam os anticorpos contra o
parasita em casos mais graves ou casos
especiais você pode estar utilizando
exames de imagem neuroimagem ou biópsias
em alguns casos
também então os medicamentos que se usam
né são alguns antibiótico chama-se
pirimetamina sufa de azina e ácido
folínico o ácido folínico no caso aí é
para repor o ácido fólico que é perdido
com a terapia com a
sufa só que esses remédios não eliminam
completamente o parasita do
organismo engem grávidas trat envolve o
uso da espiramicina
que reduz o risco de transmissão da mãe
para o
feto e os recém-nascidos vão utilizar
tratamento parecido com os adultos
usando também a sufa diazina a
pirimetamina e o ácido folínico como eu
já
mencionei infelizmente a toxoplasmose
ela não tem cura no sentido de que o
parasita vai ser totalmente eliminado
ele pode permanecer dormente no corpo
por toda a
vida e como é que você previne a
toxoplasmose com
cozimento adequado da Carne evitar o
contato com fezes de gatos né que são os
principais vetores
aí lavar as mãos de maneira frequente
evitar o consumo de água e alimentos
contaminados
fazer ressonância de coluna antes do
tratamento de ozon terapia e fazer outra
depois não vai provocar câncer não
depende faz um ano depois para não ter
muita radiação Aliás a ressonância não
tem radiação tá melhor dizendo que vai
ter radição tomografia então a
ressonância ela usa eletromagnetismo
mesmo assim por causa do contraste é bom
evitar de ficar fazendo um em cima do
outro foi você que escreveu apostila que
fala sobre dieta cetogênica Não essa
dieta melhor dizendo essa apostila ela
foi escrita por uma pessoa que eu
contratei que traduziu um material em
inglês tá Por que você
pergunta na sua possa fiquei com a
impressão de que Zon terapia não cura
não não cura mesmo ele vai ajudar no
tratamento que eu saiba não vai curar de
disco não só se for
pequena autismo e esquizofrenia leve
podem se
confundir eu acho que não porque a
esquizofrenia ela tem como
característica alucinações né e o
autista não tem alucinações não não vejo
como confundir não
olha só que Paulo tá falando
Eliseu uma ferramenta auxiliar
né não é uma cura para um monte de
doenças né como muita gente
pensa perguntei por causa de algumas
dúvidas perguntou o que Antônio Renato
vocês gostam de soltar umas coisas assim
como se a gente
tivesse fazendo em sequência né gente
muda de assunto aí fica fora de
contexto perguntei por causa de algumas
dúvidas da toxoplasmos tá
falando PRP pode ajudar muito
também alguns casos pode até curar mas
eu não contaria isso como a maioria dos
casos sobre a
apostila você tem dúvidas sobre
apostila Por que que você não deixou as
dúvidas Então nas perguntas faz as suas
suas perguntas né Nós estamos com 35
minutos de Live Mas a gente pode ter
ainda mais uns 10 a 15 minutos
respondendo dúvidas
Tá
OK mas antes de eu responder a tua
dúvida queria falar sobre o estudo
recente que liga a gordura visceral
aumento do risco de
Alzheimer então isso foi ampla ente
divulgado na mídia inclusive sai no
jornal lá em Brasília Minha mãe mandou
até a foto ter mais gordura na região
abdominal como vocês devem saber pode
aumentar a probabilidade de desenvolver
Alzheimer nós sabemos que a gura
visceral tá associada à inflamação
crônica de longa
duração e a gordura viseral aquela
gordura que tá dentro do abdômen
envolvendo as vísceras Então esse estudo
mostrou que a gordura visceral está
associado as proteínas anormais do
cérebro a betamil Loide
E a proteína
tal então observou-se que maior gordura
visceral aumenta os níveis dessas duas
proteínas
patológicas e pessoas que T HDL alto
conhecido como colesterol bom os efeitos
da gordura visceral foram parcialmente
reduzidos então é interessante que o HDL
colesterol protege até contra essa
gordura visceral
e é importante para reduzir a gordura
visceral a alimentação não inflamatória
antiinflamatória e a atividade física
regular essa pesquisa que associou a
gordura visceral com Alzheimer estudou
80 pessoas de meia idade sem problemas
cognitivos aparentes e observou a
relação entre essa obesidade visceral e
o Alzheimer
descobriu-se que a gordura visceral é
responsável por
77% do aumento de níveis de amiloide
associado a obesidade e a gordura
subcutânea não é associado a Esse
aumento de amiloide Isso aqui é uma
coisa muito óbvia para quem estuda o
material do dale braden Mas é
interessante ver que a medicina Ortodoxa
tá começando a abrir os olhos para esses
problemas
aí outro estudo revela que o fluxo
sanguíneo cerebral piora com o aumento
da gordura viceral também meio óbvio
né Outra pesquis mostra que a pressão
alta está ligada ao aumento do Risco
decia então obviamente se você tratar
pressão alta de forma correta vocêde
eliminar os efeitos negativos no cérebro
tem um estudo recente que revela que tem
uma diferença de gênero nesse tipo de
risco então homens com fator de risco
cardiovascular tem maior probabilidade
de desenvolver demência do que as
mulheres e em média 10 anos
antes então esse estudo da pressão alta
foi publicado no Journal of neurology
neurosurgery psychiatry Que analisou
34.425 participantes de um banco de
dados chamado uk biobank a idade é entre
45 e 62 anos na idade média 63 usando
então o framingham Risk score
pesquisadores avaliaram o risco
cardiovascular considerando idade
gorduras no sangue pressão arterial
sistólica medicamentos para pressão
tabagismo e diabetes Então os
pesquisadores utilizaram neuroimagem
para entender como esses riscos afetam o
cérebro com envelhecimento e descobriram
que o risco de demência associado a
problemas cardiovasculares e obesidade é
mais forte e surge 10 Anos Antes nos
homens em relação às mulheres então
entre 55 e 74 nos homens e entre 65 e 74
nas mulheres então tem essa diferença de
anos ambos os gêneros mostraram decl
cognitivo ligado ao risco cardiovascular
e obesidade visto como precursor da dem
o estudo não prova que risco
cardiovascular causa demência mas sugere
que é necessário explorar essa ligação
pesquisas anteriores já indicam a
importância de tratar problemas
cardiovasculares existentes fatores de
risco cardiovascular modificáveis com
obesidade são cruciais na prevenção de
doenças
neurodegenerativas quer dizer mais uma
coisa que tá cansado de saber quem
estuda o material do de braden que
precisa cuidado dos fatores risco
cardiovasculares para evitar doença e os
homens têm mais problema com isso que as
mulheres
deixa eu ver as perguntas aqui que vocês
têm
aqui top muito pertinente pois gordura
visceral é marcador que pode ser feito
hoje nas bioimpedâncias sim com
certeza como aumentar o HDL
hexanicotinato inositol ômega3 atividade
física
regular e óleo de
coco homo sisten ômega-3 se ela estiver
acima de sete na apostila fala que o
ômega3 não beneficia a
cognição não ela vai beneficiar sim viu
Antônio Só que você tem que cuidar da da
ocista também tá que é um fator de
risco isolado para doenças
cardiovasculares e para demência Então
por mais que tome um eg3 tem que baixar
um í tá
entendeu esclarecer a sua
dúvida bem vamos a mais uma
notícia pesquisadores Descobriram que é
possível fazer
isso que é detectado SD alheimer em em
estágios iniciais usando imagens
detalhadas da retina Então tem um exame
novo de retina para analisar mudanças
vasculares nos olhos e isso é um
indicador precoce da doença de alzheimer
nós sabemos que a retina é como uma
extensão do cérebro Então esse exame
analisar a retina ele consegue ver se a
doença está avançando ou não então o
nome do exame é
iid de Alzheimer disease então é i ifen
AD
é um instituto que usa Inteligência
Artificial algoritmos avançados para
analisar a imagem de retina muito
interessante não chegou no Brasil ainda
oferece uma forma rápida e não invasiva
para detectar o declínio cognitivo
permitindo que médicos retardem a
progressão da doença e melhor os
resultados dos
pacientes Então esse estudo
a ou
aid aplica estruturas de aprendizado
profundo né Deep learning para processar
a imagens detalhadas da retina
identificando mudanças pequenas que
seriam demais para o olho
humano então ele verifica mudanças muito
sutis que o olho humano que o olho
humano não capta né ao analisar a imagem
mas o algoritmo consegue pegar com mais
de 90% de
precisão então é mais uma ferramenta
muito interessante além do exame de
sangue para ver betamil Loide e proteína
vamos ver quando é que chega no Brasil
isso daí
né na apostila fala que pessoas que T
tendência a
sangramento e pessoas que têm histórico
familiar o risco de AVC tem que ter
cuidado sim tem que tomar cuidado
sim tem tomar cuidado com substâncias
anticoagulantes é isso que tá
falando completa essa frase aí
Antônio idose de mais de 80 anos
diabética décadas vai fazer cirurgia de
catarata quais os perigos perigo ela
desenvolve infecção pós-operatória no
caso do diabetes tá se o Diabetes não
tiver controlado e também tem um perigo
da cicatrização da cirurgia não ser
adequada por causa do diabetes que
atrapalha a
cicatrização tá aqui uma observação do T
an
Paula sim tem que tomar cuidado com
doses altas de ômega-3 que pode causar
sangramento é isso Antônio mas é dose
alta tá tenta escrever tudo bonitinho
para não ficar esse negócio picado
né fisioterapia cura herne de disco não
não cura
Eliseu não
cura pode ajudar mas não curar
mais perguntas pessoal
o que causa and
disco geralmente é uma vida inteira de
esforços a posição da pessoa ficar em pé
né e fazer esforços faz com que a o
disco eh intervertebral ele saia do
lugar o núcleo pulposo
ele dá uma proeminência para fora e
começa a comprimir nervo e Então o que
causa de disco é idade é o questão de
postura
inadequada excesso de trauma mecânico
né como prevenir tem uma postura
adequada fazer musculação fazer
atividade física
regular seria forma de prevenir isso daí
e corrigir problemas de postura de
coluna
a cura é multifatorial Eliseu e não é
para todos os casos não é para caso
higes
pequenas bem nós estamos com 46 minutos
de lives eu vou encerrar com 50 tá
bom mais perguntas
pessoal depois dessas 20 sessões tem que
fazer Ah não tem pergunta para cima
aqui o máximo de sessões que a pessoa
pode fazer de ozônio são 20 Não não é o
máximo não
Mas é bom fazer o intervalo depois de 20
sessões
Ah sim Cristina Bem
lembrado bem lembrado isso daí mas enfim
se for uma pergunta grande tenta
fazer é realmente porque o que acontece
é que quando você coloca a pergunta
alguém pode fazer outra pergunta em
seguida e vai ficar separado uma uma da
outra tem sentido você tá falando
Cristina não precisa fazer se meses de
intervalo não acho que um mês de
intervalo já é o
suficiente frango com hormônio afeta a
cetose não o hormônio vai afetar a saúde
mas não vai afetar a
cetose suplemento de óleo de orégano 80%
de carvacrol é bom é bom
de nada Antônio de
nada exatamente Carlos boa observação aí
tá
bom boa observação do Carlos
kma tá aí um bom motivo para colocar
pergunta no documento e não colocar a
pergunta aqui né porque tem
limitação dos
caracteres bem deixa eu olhar se tem
mais alguma pergunta no documento não
não tem
não bem pessoal vou encerrar por aqui tá
Agradeço muito a participação de vocês
se ficou alguma pergunta sem responder
coloque no documento para tip poder
responder na semana que vem tá bom Até
semana que vem um grande abraço a todos
vocês aí